PROFESSOR: Random walks
provide probabilistic models
for a bunch of settings.
In fact, we've seen
a couple already,
so let's examine what
they are in general.
So the set up for a random walk
is that you have a digraph,
and we can also often think
and talk about the digraph
as though it was a state diagram
for a machine with state,
so here's a three-state
digraph-- blue, orange,
and green-- and the part
that becomes probabilistic
is that we think of the
process of which edge
to follow when you're
at a given state
is made probabilistically.
And the only rules
are that we're
going to assign probabilities
to the edges in a way
like this where, for
example, what I'm
telling you is there's a 1/3
probability that I'll follow
the edge from O to O, and a 2/3
the edge from O to
green, and the rule
is simply that the sum
of the probabilities
on the outgoing edges
has to sum to 1.
So let's fill in the rest
of the graph in a legal way.
So here we have B
with a 1/2 probability
of going from B to B, a 1/4 from
B to O, and a quarter from B
to G. And the green state
is certain in one step
if you're at green
to go to blue next.
There's only one edge out.
It has probability 1.
Now, gambler's ruin can
be seen as an example
of this kind of a random walk.
The states where the amount
of money that you had,
ranging from 0 when you're
bankrupt to T when you've
reached your target and N
is the start state, which
is your initial stake, the
green edges are weighted
with a probability
P of winning a bet,
so we have transitions
from K to K plus 1 for K
less than T, with a
weight probability P
and, likewise, the red edges are
weighted with the probability
of losing a bet,
Q, or 1 minus P.
So there is a digraph,
or a state machine,
that describes the
gambler's ruin problem
as a probabilistic
walk on a graph.
And the typical kind
of question that we
would ask about a
random walk on a graph
would be, what's the
probability of reaching T,
the target, before reaching
0, bankrupt, given that you're
starting at some state And.
So in walks come up in a bunch
of quite different settings.
For example, in
physics Brownian motion
is the random motion
of a particle that's
being buffeted by
atomic forces, and its
modeled by saying
that this particle can
move in any
direction in 3D space
and chosen uniformly at random.
And the theory of
Brownian motion--
it had been observed first
without being understood.
Einstein was the first one
to come up with a random walk
model and corresponding theorems
about the behavior of particles
under Brownian motion.
In fact, that was one of the
main components of his Nobel
Prize.
He wasn't given a Nobel
Prize for relativity
at the time, because it had
not yet been firmly proven,
although it was
widely celebrated.
Another case is in finance.
We've already seen how gambler's
ruin reflects, or seems
to reflect, the biased
random oscillation of stock
prices over time,
and we will see
at the end of this set
of videos an application
of random walks on
a graph to model
web search and clustering of a
focus on vertices in a digraph.
So the general
kinds of questions
that come up when you're talking
about random walks on graphs
are illustrated by this
simple three-state example
with blue, orange, and green.
We might ask, for
example, starting
at state B, what's the
probability of reaching
state O in seven steps?
And that would be easy
enough to calculate
in this small example, but it
would be a typical question.
A more interesting
general question would be,
what's the average
number of steps that it
takes to get from B to O?
I mean, you could with
probability of 1/4,
you go there in one step,
but with probability an 1/8,
you go there in three
steps, and so on.
You can calculate again
explicitly and easily enough
what the average number
of steps from B to O
is in this simple
example, and we'll shortly
remark about general ways
to solve that problem.
And finally, you can ask a
gambler's ruin type question,
what's the probability
of starting
at B of getting to G before O?
Well, in this
trivial example, you
can just read off the answer.
You are going to get to G
before O with 50-50 probability,
because from B you have to
go one place or the other
with equal probability.
But in general,
this becomes a more
interesting and
complicated question,
which you can solve by methods
that we're about to lay out.
Let me just remind you
that we've already seen
an interesting and illustrative
example of random walk
on a graph when we were
looking at coin tosses.
The problem, for example,
of if I toss a fair coin
and I wait for three consecutive
tosses that form the pattern
HTH or the pattern
TTH, and I want
to know what's the probability
of winning because HTH comes
before TTH, I can model
that with a-- we said
with an infinite tree
diagram, using our tree
method for forming
probability spaces,
but the tree was very
recursively defined.
Sub-trees were isomorphic
to the original tree, which
allowed us, in fact, to come
up with a finite description
of the infinite tree that
amounted to a finite state
machine or finite graph.
So let's look at that
example in more detail.
If I'm trying to model
the coin flipping thing,
we start off in a state
where the previous two
flips don't exist.
I haven't flipped anything yet.
The state's going to record
the values of the previous two
flips, and with no
prior flips, there's
a 50-50 chance that the first
flip will be H, in which case
I'm in the state with just
an H and nothing preceding,
or there's a 50-50 chance
I flip a T, in which case
I'm in the state
in which there's
been a T and nothing previous.
But I can already
say something then
about the probability of
tossing HTH before TTH,
namely the probability
of winning.
The probability of
winning is, of course,
the probability of winning,
given that I start at the start
state with no prior
flips, but the probability
that I win starting
here is simply
the probability that I win
starting at the state nothing H
and where the probability
that I win at the state
started nothing T, with the two
probabilities weighted equally
since this is a fair coin,
and there's a 50-50 chance
of going each way.
That is the
probability of winning
given no prior tosses is 1/2
the probability of winning
if the first toss
is an H plus 1/2
the probability of winning
if the first toss is
a T. This is just an
application of the Law of Total
Probability.
So continuing in this way, let's
expand more of the digraph.
So suppose that I have tossed a
head and then after that I toss
a head, and I go to
state HH or I toss a T,
and I go to state HT.
So here I'm just recording
the previous two flips,
with the most recent
one on the right.
This structure of
the state diagram
tells us that if I
want to know what
the probability of winning,
given that I flipped exactly
one head at the start,
the probability is simply
by, again, total probability.
The probability of winning
from HH weighted by 1/2
and the probability of winning
from HT weighted by 1/2,
and I wind up again with a
simple linear equation that
connects the probability
of winning in one state
with the probability of winning
in the states that it goes to.
Let's continue and
do another example.
So, likewise, if I
expand what happens
after I flip a T or an H after
having flipped the first head,
I get a corresponding
equation that the probability
of winning after a single
tail is the same as 1/2
the probability of winning
with a tail followed
by an H or a tail
followed by a tail.
This is a more interesting
part of the diagram,
where suppose that my past
two flips have been two H's.
Well, if I flip an
H again, then I'm
back in state where the previous
two flips where H's, or if I
flip a T, then I'm
in this state HT,
where the previous flips were
an H and a T, in that order.
And that tells me,
if I want to know
about the probability
of winning given HH,
now it's the
probability of winning
given HH plus the probability
of winning given HT.
And, again, it's a linear
equation connecting up
the probability of
winning in one state
with the probability of winning
in other states, possibly
itself, but there's
no circularity here.
It's just a system
of linear equations.
Well, there's what the
whole diagram looks like.
In particular, once
you flipped HT,
if you then flip an H you've won
because you got to HTH first,
and you stay in the
win state forever
or, alternatively, once you
flip TT, if you flip an H
you've lost because
TT has come up first.
If you flip the T again,
you stay in state TT.
And what we can say
is the probability
of winning if we're
in the win state is 1,
and the probability of winning
if you're in a lose state is 0.
And overall, I simply
have this system
of linear equations for
the probability of winning
in one state given
other states, and I
can solve these linear
equations to find
the probability of winning
in the start state, which
is simply the
probability of winning.
So looking back at our
questions for random walks,
where we ask whether the
probability of reaching
O in seven steps starting at B,
what's the probability of that?
What's the average number
of steps to go from B to O?
What's the probability
of reaching G
before O, starting at B?
In every case, these questions
can be formulated simply
as solving systems
of linear equations
whose structure
directly reflects
the structure of the digraph.